INSTRUCTOR: The next Internet of Things scenario using Packet Tracer,
we'll look at what might be useful in a smart city type of situation.
So if we have cars driving around, there's
an old car and carbon monoxide detector to detect the exhaust gases coming out
of the car.
I'll activate the car by holding down ALT and clicking.
There's the dirty exhaust gases.
And then say this is a tunnel or a poorly ventilated area, we
can put a fan in place so that ultimately whenever too many gases are
detected by the CO detector, when an old car is parked in the area,
the fan can be activated to blow them away and protect
the health of the people in the area, clear the tunnel out,
or some other similar situation.
Obviously, at the moment, I'm just clicking
on these they're not at all connected.
We can look at that later on as to how they might connect
to each other over different networks.
While we're in the smart city situation, they
have a street lamp here which detects light,
so it will only come on when it's dark enough to be needed,
and motion so it will only come on when there's a car near by.
You can see as I move this car here the M lights up green
showing that it's got motion detection.
OK.
That's a few different ways you can make use
of devices such as street lamps or carbon monoxide detectors
or being connected to each other via the network
to make things talk to each other and provide Internet of Things type
solutions automatically.